τους θαλάμους όπουμε επιτρέπεται βέβαια και μάλιστα πολλές φορές ζητώ αν θέλουν κάποιο ασθενίς να
να να τους μιλήσωυ να δούν ότι είμαστε επτήναι αυτή ευρωπαϊκή ένωση ακούν βριξα λεστι
είμαστε είμαστε εκεί ίμωσα ένα παιδιατρικώ νοσοκομειών κολογικό στη ρόμη και περπατούσαν περνούσε από το
διάδρομο και είδα μέσα από ένα παραθυρά και μια κιθρα σα έναγκρεβάτη καιρώτησα το γιατρο
ποιο συνεδώ και μο λύ είναι ας νεωρός ραφαή ο οποίος έχι καρκίνο και πέζι
κιθάρα και λέο μπορώ να του μιλήσω και πήκα μέσα και βρήκα έναν αγοράκι με
τη μαμμά του και του υπαείμε ητάδε ξέριστεη δουλειά κάνω σιγουρα δεν ήξερε το κ
είμασα να το εξηγήσο και του ίπα θα ίθελες να που πέξεις ένα κομμάτι με
την κιθάνα και επι δεν πέροχαπραγματικά φεύγοντά στόσο το κινητόμου όπως κάνο πριν δύο ιτρεις
μήνες πήρα ένα μήν ίμας στο κινητό μουύμε μια φωτογραφία του μικρού από την άπολύ
με την κιθάραντου και να μου λέει μητέρα το ότι θέλαμε να σας πούμε ότι
προχωρήσαμε κάναμε τη μεταμόσκυψη μιελού ώρα θα ήλει είναι παρα πολύ καλά και ήθελε να
σας τίλουμε αυτή τη φωτογραφία και να σας περιμένουμε στην άπολη και λέω αυτό για
μένα καλύτεριανταμηβίο είναι καλύτερι ανταμιβή από ολλά αλλά που θα θαθα μετρείσει κάποιος δι ότι
ήξερα ότι εκείνη τη στιγμή αγκύξαμε την τηνψυχί αυτού του παιδιού που το είχε ανάγκη
και μας έγκοιωσε δίπλα του και μετά από τρεις μήνες πικοινώνησε μαζί μας και έχω
σκοπό να έχω ξανά επαφη μαζί του είμαστε στον οκτόύριο στο μήναυεσιςτοποίησις